which is for absence Glenn thank you
Charlie disclosures of interest and he
disclosed his win turist I'll take that
as a no minutes confirm and so in the
minutes of the meeting held on 13th of
January yes
mr. Harvey sorry captain rock the
courtesy of consistency Thank You
counselor Harvey any more comments on
the minutes in that case subject to the
amendments put forward by counsel Harvey
will accept the minutes
so moving on item for response to the
final report from the climate emergency
task and finish group we are responding
to that as a cabinet you will notice on
the 1.1 that the cabinet were to discuss
the proposals in the item be brought
back to their March meeting we
considered it sooner and given the
significance of this we thought we will
bring it back to this meeting if we are
very keen to explore with the Tuscan
finish group the context within the
record within which the recommendations
have been made we are proposing using a
different governance model which is
outlined in the paper and we think the
establishment of a standing panel of the
cabinet will provide for greater
accountability more timely decision
making you will say they in appendix
to the draft of the terms of reference
there is one change I do Mitch wish to
make in the objectives where it says so
as to minimize or eliminate carbon
emissions that should be change to read
achieve the aim of being carbon neutral
by 2030 which was what the council
actually agreed to so that was just a
mistake in drafting so if we look at
this the standing panel we're talking
about is an advisory body we will
include cabinet members and counselors
drawn from across the council so without
any discussion any debate members of
cabinet councillor Perry thank you thank
you chairman well first of all I just
wanted to say what an excellent report
oscy brought forward gives us a very
much a diligent pathway and in
particular with the recommendations
particularly good to see that
adaptations will be considered under an
adaptation policy but I did just want to
highlight just a slight concern over 0.5
in Appendix 1 which highlights the
objective of getting more properties
rated under the EP seas between a and C
it just so happens I spend two days a
week of my other hat looking at EP seas
in the property mark
and as a both honor lettings on a sales
side and I can advise cabinet that I
mean obviously in a lettings perspective
you can't put a letting property on the
market until they reach a knee we're
having expensive issues with properties
across the district because we're in a
rural district and the properties are
quite old but a number of properties are
having to be registered on the EPC
exemption register and that can be done
when the installation costs exceed three
and a half thousand but most of the
quotes we're finding for very old
properties just to get them up to an e
rating is between four and six thousand
so my concern relates to the fact that
getting properties to be as high as a C
really equates to properties built in
the 1990s onwards so it's quite an
ambitious target wearing my hat of
looking at e pcs every well certainly
two days a week to try and get them to
to raise to a see even my property that
was built in nineteen ninety seven is a
D and that's a modern box so I just
wanted to highlight that this particular
area will need extensive research Thank
You councillor Perry councillors unit
how am I correct in assuming you wish to
make a point on the point raised by
councillor Perry yes it's just a
technical point because under the fuel
poverty act requirements which is
government requirements there are two
dates that all letter rental properties
will have to meet one is to April 2025
when they will have to meet an EPC of
level D or above and the other one is
1st of April 2030 when all letters rent
residential rental properties will have
to meet a minimum EPC of level C or
above so that is government policy
anyway Thank You counselor Junaid it
looks as though implementing government
policy may be somewhat expensive any
more comments questions for members of
cabinet in that unless I'm
misunderstanding or miss reading this
0.5 the the recommendation specifically
is develop a program to improve home
installation across the district not to
improve it to a minimum Bansi it goes on
to say with the measurement that well
insulated homes on an EPC rating are
those of a B or C what is and say we
have to meet that minimum standard once
it might be a nice thing to do and the
point is I think these probably accept
is the recommendation is actually just
to develop a program to improve rather
than to a minimum standard Thank You
councillor Richards any more comments
questions from members of cabinet yes
councillor Barker just on page Oh the
end of the appendix 1 page 15 so it
sideways to produce a list the key
transport priorities I know that's
something that we're working on but just
to say that I've had introductory
discussions I supposed to exploratory
discussions with vasa about this already
in terms of this scheme I want to bring
forward which is caught to do with car
sharing and that's certainly potentially
part of that which would reduce things
so soon you will see a magnetic thing on
my car saying councillor Barker will
give you a lift if you contact me on
this app probably Thank You councillor
Barker councillor kettle I was just
going to remind those listeners that
actually when we first set this up
was produced that this was the first
step that we were taking forward and
clearly this doesn't delimit any future
improvements and additions that might
take place no indeed councillor kettle
and I think one should say in all
honesty that this is likely to be a
dynamic and change in environment in
terms of climate change not only on
mitigation but also perhaps particularly
given the events of the weekend
adaptation councillor Richards thank you
chair members I find myself in somewhat
of a quandary here in that on the one
hand I'm pleased to see the report has
come back to cabinet a month earlier
than originally expected albeit delayed
from our January meeting and that
clearly shows a willingness by the by
the council to press on with action on
the issue of climate emergency but on
the other hand I'm somewhat disappointed
by the recommendation for a cabinet led
panel rather than the previously agreed
standing panel of the overview in
scrutiny I believe the latter would
ensure good governance and open and
transparent decision-making this is a
concern shared by the members of our
overview and scrutiny committee our
meeting on the 5th of February I first
put on record both the scrutiny
committee and my personal appreciation
that the cabinet are recommending to
accept the recommendations an action
plan presented by the task and finish
group the outcomes of the work of that
task and finish group clearly
demonstrates the benefits of cross
working across party working however I
would like to draw his attention to the
third recommendation and the terms of
reference in Appendix two which seeks to
bring forward a cabinet standing panel
for action on climate change in the
climate emergency in the past the
cabinet this cabinet has given its
commitment to improving the scrutiny
function and in particular developing
pre-decisional scrutiny a point I've
made on a number of occasions in this
forum unfortunately the approach
outlined in the report calls into
question that commitment if approved
will be in a position where a cabinet
group will be making recommendations to
the cabinet with the opportunity for
proper public pre decision scrutiny by
the overs over
and scrutiny committee limited to a
review of the published cabinet papers
papers that are only made available to
OSC members to business days prior to
the scrutiny missing scrutiny committee
meeting advice given to me by an
external scrutiny expert has outlined
that this is an example of bad decision
making and a bad decision-making process
and is a deep concern in effect cabinet
members will be asked to rubber-stamp
their own recommendations for that
reason I've already defined my
willingness to sit on this panel as it
is in that as it is the role of scrutiny
to hold to account the cabinet and their
decision making process by sitting on
the panel I would in essence be
condoning the suggested approach
outlined in the report whilst also
undermining the role of independent
scrutiny by being asked to scrutinize
the decision which I had been apart in
October in November last year the
cabinet approved in principle a series
of recommendations put by the task and
finish group these included establishing
a standing panel of the overview and
scrutiny committee and to King that
would then continue to do the excuse me
cook would continue the work of the
original task and finish group this
cabinet report is seeking a departure
from that agreement in favor of a
cabinet in favour of a cabinet panel
with no real alternatives being
presented in a rather vague reason for
departing from a previously agreed
approach this is my understanding the
report outlining three alternative
options were presented to the cabinet at
a cabinet forum meeting yet there is no
discussion or debate on those options
within this report
indeed the task and finish members total
finish group members were not consulted
on these alternative options from an
openness and transparency perspective
these options and the consideration
given to each should be presented for
public scrutiny and debate today absent
of that report and the detail
surrounding it does I fear make a
decision made today and future decisions
made by the Cabinet through this
governance process very much vulnerable
to call in on that basis and on behalf
of the entire scrutiny committee a
request that you accept recommendations
one to and for the employee to
reconsider recommendations three and
reissue the report to include all
options considered and a detailed
of those options for open public debate
and discussion thank you Joe Thank You
councillor Richards members of cabinet
any comments or observations councillor
JUnit also second what councillor
Richards has said when I moved the
original motion I deliberately sought
cross-party approach I did not move it
as just from my own party but
deliberately made sure that all people
that they will involve because this is
far too important an issue I believe it
must remain with an overview and
scrutiny function again because this is
a very complex issue it it does require
a very different approach in policy and
operational terms than anything else
that council has done before it doesn't
sit comfortably within any one function
any one group or any one a department it
does require a very different way of
thinking and governing to address very
complex issues one of the pretty
important thing is to make sure that we
do carry all counselors with us in this
very very complex journey that we've got
ahead but even more importantly that we
carry with us all the members of the
residents of this district as well it
will be in people's homes and
communities that the impact of climate
change will be felt it will impact on
the most vulnerable parts of our
communities as well we must it must not
become must not become a political
football in any shape form or whatever
we must make sure that we work together
and that there it because there's too
much at stake that but we also must test
and scrutinize and make sure that
decisions taken are sound and sound at
the first step that we take not waiting
until something has happened that has
gone wrong we have we have a very
crucial window short window to get
things right you know I do really do
believe that we must carry everybody
with us and I would like to see this as
a standing panel and
which is not the one that is in in in
point three come upon Town Council at
the membership of the proposed panel is
very much cross-party it was never
intended used to be one party we fully
recognized the need to take everyone
with us I think when I would pick up as
well as the point you made about this
being a very complex issue and one that
may well require a different approach
and I think in all honesty that's what
we were trying to do with our proposals
with cabinet any comments councillor
Pemberton I think Thank You leader I
think just to first of all just to
reinforce the point that this isn't a
party political thing at all I don't
think that anybody in this room anybody
in the wider council itself thinks of it
in such terms I think this is one of
those issues which does transcend and I
think that everybody in this council
chamber back at the time that we held
the debate on a climate emergency
absolutely accepted and bought into that
and I think I would just reiterate and
and I my thinking has evolved and
changed on this whole thing in terms of
we all agree that this is the most
fundamental issue that faces us and I'm
of the view that in many ways the
traditional structures don't necessarily
fit what we're all trying to do and
there are in terms of ensuring good
governance good decision-making and
being clear and transparent I'd be
struggling to find anybody in this room
or again in the wider council who would
disagree with that but I think what we
are trying to do is to find a more
responsive way to look at this issue in
the long term and for it to ensure and
for it to be enshrined as something
that's
is part and parcel of whatever
administration runs this council does
from day one in terms of it has whoever
is the leader of this Authority whatever
political badge they wear or not it is
something that has their attention as a
key as a key priority and so I've I've
come to the conclusion although you will
note there is a there is a proposal for
a discussion with the overview scrutiny
we talked about process here we all want
to get we all want to do exactly the
same thing we all want to get to the
same place and as quickly as possible so
I think we're there is a bit of a
process thing there now they I think we
just need to understand this is a
process discussion not a discussion
about whether we're doing this whether
we're gonna be ambitious or not so my
view is more responsive and to be able
to deliver better I think there is a
role for absolutely there's a role for
scrutiny in all of this and I would I
would actually suggest that's why we've
got the question of you know sitting
down with the the task and finish group
of overview and scrutiny itself to
finesse this thing and to ensure that
everybody understands that this is the
best way forward and if there's tweaks
then we need to tweak it because we
already have to buy into it okay
councillor Whaley Huggins
thank you I would just like to say this
this transcends everything as counts of
gender said it is not a political
football that we can use here and that
is certainly not what the council is
planning to do and the cross party
initiative here states that very clearly
that there is balance however I wonder
if some consideration and very serious
consideration could be given to doing
something quite remarkable which is
actually to seek people and citizens
that have a very deep-seated interest in
this I note for example that we have a
lot of observers here today
I wondered if perhaps we could give a
voice to senior school representatives
on this
yes it's dynamic yes it's unusual but it
is giving a voice to the ordinary person
and those people to whom this stuff
really does matter
thank you your point is no tea
councillor Whaley Huggins councillor
Junie my polishers citizens panel style
process it doesn't actually say citizens
panel because actually there are many
different styles that have been used
across the country and there's been
about three councils that have used its
actual citizens panel panels per se but
there's also been other councils that
have used either symposiums or
commissions that have involved members
of the public and and this is one of the
things that irrespective of what the
final decision is is one of the things
that we're recommending that we much
must bring in wider a range of citizens
groups as well as experts into this this
debate debate I think that will be an
early issue for discussion councillor to
mid cardio thank you nothing to disagree
with really yeah the one thing I will
say is this what my understanding of
when we were talking about setting up
this group under this guidance here was
so we could be done on me it could be
fast-acting that was all point of this
and that's why I bought into this if in
the future it doesn't work that we tweak
it yeah but we can involve this whole
process but the point being that it was
the whole concept of this was so we
could react quickly through the cabinet
so yeah I don't buy into what council
registered in that particular point I
think this is worth a good try now
councillor Barker I just want to make
the point that actually contrary to the
direction that auditing pathetical to
what we're saying is going we have
actually as a cabinet put the
higher up the list of priorities that we
might have otherwise and giving it more
urgency and importance and that's the
reason for the weight of that group can
I also say one thing that I've found
since I've been a district counselor
that we spend an inordinate amount of
time on planning matters and I note the
comments in the original report on page
23 that were from the Tanner Country
Planning Association and the RTP RTP I
recommending that climate change at
Astoria climate adaptation must be
understood as the main priority for long
term planning to secure climate
resilience and must be accepted as
equally as important as meeting housing
need so it's the balance that is
changing for so many of us and I hope
that we will perceive it like that and I
also hope that when I go to meetings
with developers in future and say to
them it's about time we started building
north-south and that we put water butts
on things that they might take me more
seriously okay any more debate any more
discussion in that case we have two
options I believe we have accept
recommendations one for four as outlined
on page nine or what councillor Richards
is suggesting that we accept councilors
we accept recommendations one two and
four so let's do first recommendations
one to four as outlined in the paper
all in favor agreed in that case that's
carried cabinet thank you moving on item
five revenue and capital but I'm sorry
no we have reordered it because if we
have not we need to take we need to take
the paper on the market supplement from
the employment and appointments
committee so this is page 83
and can I just outline that we had we
are as you know going for two jobs we
don't forehead of resources and
transformation and we are going for a
head of community and operational
services at the meeting we had of the
employment at points committee there
were enough good quality applications to
progress with the head of customers and
head of community in operational
services we did not think we had enough
candidates of the right quality to
progress with the head of transformation
resources and transformation the
feedback we got from West Midlands
employers very definitely and we have
their bond the telephone conferencing
during the meeting was that the salary
we were offering simply was not high
enough the reality is there were jobs
advertised at the same time on a much
higher salary the feedback we actually
got was that we would need a summary of
at least 75,000 to be attractive to good
quality candidates as an employment and
appointments committee we discussed
whether or not a market supplement
should of the up to 75,000 or up to
80,000 the unanimous decision of
employment and appointments was that we
should go up to 80,000 that's not 80,000
a market supplement but a total package
of 80,000 one of the realities of that
was that if you look on page 85 point
113 to
that that may well create an issue with
other heads of service there will be a
formal review of salary levels for heads
of service so in order to progress the
recruitment process for the head of
resources and transformation you will
see the recommendation there that
cabinet provides up to thirteen thousand
seven hundred from the general fund
reserves to fund a market supplement for
the post of head of resourcing and
transformation any questions issues or
debate members of cabinet counsel aware
Lee Huggins yes to why it works you
think that we need to go up to eighty
thousand when a lot of the with the
majority of the benchmarking documents
we've got here indicates that seventy
five thousand would be adequate I'd also
like details please on the relocation
package and I'm very conscious of the
knock-on effect that an 80,000 pound
salary award would have the reason
employment and appointments took the
decision to go to eighty sounds and
dwars
we just wanted to give a bit of extra
head room above the seventy five
thousand and we did not want to have to
keep coming back for another decision so
we don't necessarily think we will have
to pay eighty thousand but we just
wanted that additional Headroom on this
second point of relocation package
I'm afraid that's not a detail I've got
to hand it's currently frozen we've only
used a couple of times in the last five
years we would think that we would
probably make it available for this
particular post if it wasn't necessary
can also make a point that as drafted
the original recommendation was seeking
to fund this from general fund raiser
we put this report together in somewhat
of a hurry and with hindsight it seems
better that we consider it as part of
the overall budget papers as why item
six has now been taken before item five
and the additional supplement papers
that George and Trevor have circulated
would seek to ax conclude this within
the base budget for 2021 onwards I think
one thing I would just add counselor
Whaley Huggins we actually see this rule
has been very important to the council
and we do need somebody who's absolutely
right for the role and it is very
interesting that we had more than you
know for Kelly
high caliber applicants for the other
role and not for this one and I think it
is fair to say there would appear to be
a scarcity of good people available at
the price we were offering so what will
be what is the effect then if we make an
80,000 pound pay award to to do this do
it do we know what the moment we don't
but that's where the review of all those
salaries will come in there was an
original benchmark in doing a very quick
benchmarking that indicates the salaries
were adequate and the interesting thing
is of course that for the other role the
head of community and operational
services the salary we're offering
attractive you know for telling the
candidate councilor Cargill thank you
thank you later I think it's important
to recognize that we are experiencing
market forces here we need those high
quality people to carry this council
forward all the projects that we've got
four are going at them
and it's vital we have the right skills
in place it's the market forces we will
have to pay that rate if we need that
right person it's as simple as that
we don't want to spend any more than we
absolutely have to as a council
obviously on the on salaries or anything
at all but we need that role filling we
need it filling as soon as as possible
and we need that high caliber person in
that role as to do the job it's a big
job as well mr. Buckland did you want to
make a point
church hymn thank you know you've got
the councillors wishing to speak I just
wanted to make the point that market
forces supplement is a temporary
supplement on on the basics Hawaii and
that's why again it would be meso to
undertake the wider review now I'm
absolutely accept that when we went out
to advert there were three other posts
in the municipal journal all over
section one five one officer position at
district councils paying at seventy five
thousand pounds and that is effectively
the market rate for six month one
officers ahead of service level if we
want to make ourselves attractive to
somebody why would they come to the
local authority when they've already
received in their salary in their own
authority so that's I believe was the
thinking behind that the important and
pointless decision comes from the
capital
thank you side mean I completely support
where this is coming from I had one
question we did have a hiccup last year
in the appointment of a seen you
exception to this council in the event
that the individual was to decide during
that probationary period at Stratford
wasn't for them would the relocation
costs be refundable would we have access
to call them back to the first proper
pushes in the second part if somebody
leaves within the two-year period tests
they'll be quite to be paid that
relocation pending these persons
councillor Richards thank you chair this
is an discussed reasonable length at
arts
in committee last week a number of
issues arising one of which was
consideration given to the salary levels
existing several levels of your
executives which you've obviously
outlined in the report and spoken to
just now has any consideration being
given to the effect that may have on
other staff members throughout the
officer corps and also it seems
13700 seems to along or quite a large
uplift from the original quoted salary
are we absolutely convinced that we're
going to get the right parts and as a
result of that uplift or is there a
danger that the the the role briefed is
quite a niche I know this is the
resource and transformation and that's
one five one off so they seem quite they
don't necessarily seem to go hand in
glove but you may be able to give me
advice to other ones the discussions we
actually had on the day with the
representative from West Midlands
employees who had spoken to most
potential candidates so we're actually
getting a good feedback in terms of the
potential candidates out there they were
sure and reassured is that there were
people out there who could do the role
as outlined I think what one has to say
is we have learned an awful lot of
lessons from our previous recruitment
round that was less than successful and
we are determined not to repeat the same
mistakes again one can never however
guarantee can making any recruitment and
selection decisions that you get it
right a hundred percent of the time
certainly in my experience in the area
which is extensive you don't get it
right a hundred percent of the time its
recruitment isn't straightforward
correct
so I do understand that if if we find
that so making this decision today if we
find that we don't get an appropriate
candidate have to reject the structure
and somebody's obviously would be
separating for example yes five one five
one and the resources transformation
presumably that the commitment we're
making today will already have had a
knock-on effect to the count the
executive councils as salary so we'll
already have made that change how does
that work will it be setting stone or is
that something that would get Sri verses
if this changes not simple question no
not a simple question answer the council
has approved that the management
structure that we're now seeking to
recruit into this actually isn't the
13,700 market forces supplement market
forces supplement of up to ten thousand
two hundred and seventy pounds and then
overheads took years to the thirteen
thousand seven hundred and it was clear
although it didn't attend the employment
point committee that it was the
intention that they should be up to that
level so the appointment can be made
lower than that level then fantastic and
that's what we will do as an
organization while we've been I suppose
quite vague at the moment the package
will be able to a two thousand that's
how we will be advertising and that if
the subsequent review of the head of
service salary suggested the substantive
posts they should be paid seventy five
thousand and that would make the market
forces supplement and this regard up to
five thousand so it will be effectively
the balancing pick up to five thousand
we do use market forces supplement your
question about but in the rest of the
organization we already use that where
necessary and we will continue to use it
where necessary where it's proven that
there is difficulty in recruiting to a
particular role and this has been a role
that's been proven difficult to recruit
into can I just also clarified counselor
which is because I missed answering the
other question you had employment at
appointments committee is only concerned
with deployment of
Seanie people heads of service and above
so what happens as a knock on is not
really our issue unfortunately
sorry just unclear on that cuz that's
kind of actually make me a little less
clear on things so the knock-on effect
is exclusively to the senior levels as
the heads of paid service I'm saying
about market supplements shoulder and
leather that it would affect the rest of
the officer corps as well or is a
different market sell physical a [ __ ]
on that particular point we have applied
market forces supplements when we have
had to across the organization on
specific occasions and we have done that
and though there were currently some
offices within this organization I
received market forces supplements the
other role that we're recruiting into
we're not going to consider it a market
forces supplement because there's a
leader suggested we had sufficient
applicants for that role without the
need to offer in that supplement this
role has proved difficult to recruit to
and therefore that's why the committee
is suggesting a market forces supplement
what we're considering here today is
actually how that market forces
supplement is financed not really
whether a market forces habberman should
be applied in our it's really the
financing issue I would also point out
yet again that actually it was the
unanimous view of employment and
appointment committee which is
cross-party that we should offer a
market supplement on this counselor huh
thank you Miss James pointed information
to address I had a conversation last
week with the leader of the Walker
County Council who make the point to me
that they're in her experience which is
very recent there is a national shortage
of local authority accountants people
who prepare to serve in local government
and to the point where in a recent
exercise work she County Council had to
go through three rounds of recruitment
before they found their
their prints they kissed a lot of frogs
okay any further comments or questions
counsel Shenton it's very quick fun -
thank you what seems obvious to me is
that in actual fact we're not good we
have to pay this supplement because
obviously we want the right caliber
person we're not going to get any but if
we go for if we don't pay that
supplement we're going to get somebody
that's not really up to the quality that
we want one thing's for sure that whilst
we can't guarantee success you can
virtually guarantee that it won't work
if we pay well under the market rate so
my opinion is that we should pay this
regardless Thank You councillor Shenton
any further comments in that case
members of cabinet can I have your
agreement - the recommendation I think
given that we are now going to consider
who isn't actually to consider it from
general fund reserves but he's actually
considered as part of the 2020 2012
budget saving process so in other words
we don't take the recommendation that
the recommendation chairman would be
that the cabinet provides up to thirteen
thousand seven hundred as to 410 three
markets under the 2000 2021 budget
process fine thank you mr. Bookman
so taking mr. book lemon mr. Buckland
recommendation are we happy with the
recommendation yes good thank you
cabinet so moving back now to item five
Chancellor Harvey
thank you
following the cabinet's approval of the
revenue budget capital budget for the
forthcoming year on the 13th of January
it has been the subject of consultation
with the citizens of Panem
the non-domestic rate payers and the
OSCE task and finish group the outcome
of these consultations have been set up
in the respective appendices to this
paper the citizens panel response
signifies a significant expression of
support as reported in tables four and
five for the maintenance of services and
the increasing pressure of support for
improvements to those levels even if
this were to mean an increase in council
tax above the five pounds increase
proposed the beating of the non-domestic
rate payors panel was attended by 13
people where the section 1/5 one officer
made a presentation and answered a
series of questions those present
appreciated that the council's role in
relation to non-domestic rates was to
administer the system rather than to set
the rates to be paid it was evident that
the role of the future car parking for
charges and support generally for
businesses within Stratford was a matter
of concern the proposed budget has also
been the subject of scrutiny at two
meetings of the OSC budget task and
finish group whilst it's not the role of
this task and finish week to approve the
proposed budget it is the group's role
to come to a view as to whether the
proposed budget is financially sound in
their view and capable of being
delivered and both criteria they came to
the view that it was indeed the case its
proposed therefore that members of the
cabinet
accept the recommendations 1 to 5
presented in the summary at the head of
this paper that the proposal set out in
parentheses 4 5 6 & 7 are approved under
the council tax verb and D property be
increased by 5 pounds the equivalent an
increase of 3.6% to be set at 144 pounds
and 12 pence with this proportionate
rate that increased being applied to the
remaining property bounds I wonder if I
could then go on to deal with the
question of the supplementary matter of
pension contributions in the past 2
weeks or so we've been approached by
worker pension fund with an offer to
make our contributions that we would
otherwise have paid over the next three
years to pay them as a prepayment as a
little so much the advantage of doing
that is that this would lead to a
reduction of three point seven percent
below what we otherwise would have paid
in round terms that is of the order of a
cash saving of three hundred and
forty-eight thousand pounds calculator
in my head tells me that that is the
equivalent of two years increase in
council tax at the rate of two percent
that is a significant amount of money
the alternate would be to hold the cash
and and generate a return the return
that we currently earn as the members of
the Treasury cash management group will
know is of the order of 0.7 percent so
that it makes financial sense to pay
this bill which we otherwise would have
paid any way to pay it up front to take
the benefit of the 3 point 7 percent
discount and to save this council catch
sum of three hundred and forty eight
thousand pounds
I think subject to my elders and betters
I think that puts the proposal
succinctly any questions any comments
members of cabinet Chancellor Cargill
whilst I fully and happy to support that
one has to ask the question why why are
they asking for the lump sum do we
happen to know that thank you it was a
proposition that was put by the
districts and other employers to the
county was it a possibility could we
take advantage of any discount if we
paid upfront and that counties actually
looked into it and this was the proposal
that came forward it will be that the
pension fund has that money available to
invest and generally returns upon it
that they wouldn't otherwise get until
at the end of the three-year period any
more questions
sorry councillor Harvey to strike it
another note of reassurance for Council
Cargill it is not long being the case
that the pension scheme has had it's one
of its triennial valuations and set its
contribution rates and those
contribution rates have been shaved
somewhat from what they were approves
the in other words they the pension
scheme is in a healthy state to the
point where it can afford to ask for
slightly lower contributions over the
next three years and otherwise would
have done I don't think would if the
implication might be in some people's
minds that the pension scheme is
desperate for it to cash I don't think
that's the case thought and the evidence
points the opposite way Thank You
councillor Harvey can solution to the
discretionary charges in pendeks 5 quite
a few of them are remained remain the
same obviously and I know that some are
set nationally or statutory but is there
any
has a review of all of these happened or
it will happen going forward wondering
if there's any any opportunity for
further games he's not going to miss the
hill yeah we we have this year looked at
the most significant options we could
take and we all know what they are with
garden waste and the car parking charges
it is worth having a review of all the
others but as you said in your question
quite a number of them are set either by
statute or are limited because we cannot
increase them above a certain level all
make surfaces in that particular area so
we will have a look at them but it's
it's the next phase if you come to
Richard's Thank You mr. boffins response
to councillor Cargill's question raised
this in my mind you suggested that the
pension fund may be asking for more
funds because they can invest it and
make a higher return on that what's to
prevent us from doing exactly that with
our own assets our own cash and if it's
restrictions is it works uh sorry
reviewing the investment restrictions
that may be placed upon its authority
are very limited in what we investment
instruments are available to ourselves
and basically we're using effectively
cash deposits money market funds
remember investments the the pension
fund though doesn't act under the same
restrictions as ourselves and they have
access to equity markets in emerging
markets that we we just simply as a
local authority cannot invest at
consumption and it has been in those
particular areas where there have seen
good returns recently can't allocate to
the second if you don't mind share was a
second question i hasn't been answered
so in terms of our own restrictions are
those restrictions imposed by us or are
they imposed by national government this
national so there's no way of receiving
it would be able to rise to
in phone markets that's right thank you
very much
councillor Javed you wish to respond to
that before robbing other councillors it
absolutely wanted to make the point that
a local authority has very different
investment requirements and time scales
and horizons than there's a pension fund
all ours is essentially short-term
management of cash essentially whereas
the pension scheme is there to ensure
there are there is a flow of income to
pay pensions over the period of 30 40
even 50 years councillor careful loan
counselors unit very very small point in
the paper that limits cabins have been
given which is headed up the report on
budget toxicant finish group on to point
to a two point three three there's a
reference to appendices three and four
which aren't actually attached to the
paper I was just wondering it doesn't
add n to think of this stage to the
debate but I just wonder the purpose of
record whether those could be added to
the papers when they were subsequently
filed yes sorry that's my fault I think
they did have some relevance to the OPM
scrutiny committee but I felt that they
weren't that needed in that much detail
at this committee and I should take that
breath and stuff so I do apologize you
can't read unit yeah I picked up on that
2.3.3 as well but just on the parking
charges just as a query it says in two
point six point one that the budget
includes an assumed inflationary
increase in parking from from June 2020
I'm assuming that it that's already been
built in the increase will already be
built in into the next four years as
well that's about two million pounds if
so I just wanted to be sure that that is
already been built in mr. him yes it has
it has been built in that particular
references to the fees and charges where
we we haven't reflected the new fees and
charges because they have
- yet been approved so the fees and
charges with appendix reflects the old
charges they will be revised following
the public consultation and their
decision by a council
okay so I'm gonna no further come to the
Catalan just came back to that point I
mean the report here is the one that was
presented in scrutiny and that would
include those two appendices I do think
it would be appropriate that they were
filed with them attached good right if
there are no further comments then the
recommendations on page 19
recommendations to cabinet one and two
are you in favor of those
recommendations members of cabinet
agreed and the recommendations to
Council three four and five are you in
agreement with that members of cabinet
and in the supplementary paper which
used to realize proposed capital and
revenue budget the full council
recommendation 1 which is additional
cost of 13,700 is that acceptable and
recommendations to council on the lump
sum prepayment to with the pension fund
is that acceptable Thank You members of
cabinet so treasury management strategy
statement councillor Harvey
there is an annual requirement under the
guidance issued by the military for
housing communities and local government
for councils to drop and approve an
annual investment strategy that meets
the Chartered Institute of public
finance and the countess's treasury
management code of practice this
council's proposed treasury management
strategy is set out on pages 93 to 119
for the forthcoming year in Appendix 1 I
draw to the attention of members of the
cabinet just one aspect of this appendix
on page 1 1 3 you will see that the
expectation for investment earns in the
immediate future remains low and given
the uncertain times in which we live the
prospect of any rise in investment
returns is both uncertain and modest
appendix 2 on pages 121 to 136 sets out
the proposed capital and investment
strategy for the period twenty twenty
twenty one to twenty twenty four twenty
five this proposal provides the
framework within which it is intended
the council should make its capital and
investment decisions over the next five
years on the assumption that members of
the cabinet have familiarized themselves
with these papers and subject to any
questions they may have
I ask that approval is given to the
recommendations one to four set out in
the summary at the head of this paper
Thank You mr. chairman any questions or
comments members of cabinet councillors
Shenton
sorry are you really sure
page 108 and it may it may just be me
maybe my on the reading for there in the
one two three fourth paragraph down it
says in bold central banks etc and this
will I think Canton has drawn a blank
[Music]
Thank You members of cabinet it's always
nice to have a little amusement going
through the meeting with unit actually
found this these papers extremely
interesting I really did I read read the
random through the one thing I want to
ask though is about one particular thing
that came up and was mentioned ten times
during in the whole paper and that's
about brexit uncertainty and brexit risk
given that that is men mentioned so many
times I really do think that not just
one yearly annual update history we need
we need to be if there is anything that
come happens that has has an impact or a
potential impact on this council and its
finances during the process during this
next year and that we are properly
updated and kept up to speed and
everything Thank You counselors unit and
I think each probably beyond the
capacity of a district council to look
in detail at the impact of brexit
or indeed the coronavirus there is an
economic contingency group at the West
Midlands combined Authority who while
keeping an eye on Briggs it and I would
imagine that they can be asked to keep
an eye on the impact of coronavirus as
well server to the extent that we get
updates from the West Midlands combined
authority on those issues I will make
sure that cabinet is updated so with
that counselor Harvey the tip just to
make a very obvious point that the
impending spending review is a far more
importance in terms of what would
actually affect directly this council as
their finances then thank you with that
then the recommendations to Council on
page 89 are members of cabinet happy
with that thank you
Prudential indicators once again
councillor Harvey Thank You mr. chair in
conjunction with considering this budget
for the forthcoming year the council is
required by the sips of Prudential code
to set Prudential indicators that ensure
that its capital investment plans for
affordable proven and sustainable paper
under consideration said that the
factors that the council through its
section 1 5 1 officer is required to
take into account when considering the
affordability in its particular
circumstances of its intended capital
expenditure over the period with the
medium term in finance and strategy and
the affordability of the capital
financing requirement which this
intended expenditure may give rise
members of the cabinet will have noted
the intention set out in paragraph 3
point 6 point 1 on page 144 the one to
incur an expenditure of 5 million pounds
in the materials recycling facility as
indicated
in the first table on page 141 and the
financing requirement to which this will
give rise and set out in the subsequent
table in paragraph three point two point
six section one five one officer has
satisfied himself but the terms
associated with its course of action
will in his view meet the requirements
set out in detail in paragraph two point
seven cabinet is therefore asked to
approve the recommendation set out in
the summary at the head of this report
that the proposed Prudential indicators
for the forthcoming year be approved
Thank You mr. chairman
people wishing to speak can we actually
approve the recommendation on page one
three seven please members of cabinet
great thank you
item nine councillor Barker this is not
going to be light relief present to you
the first stage of the joint strategic
needs assessment process and the action
plans that go with it the joint
strategic needs assessment provides us
with very solid a very solid evidence
base to frankly underpin everything we
do and if there's any doubt in that let
me just use three examples one of which
is planning if we don't get our planning
right we have people living in the wrong
place and they're not gonna have good
well-being if we don't build the right
houses their well-being is also going to
be affected if we don't do environmental
health then there might be well nasty
things in the street that we don't want
to find and the health would be affected
I won't go on fast needless to say the
evidence-based provided by this
supporting the wider determinants of
health tell us a lot about what we
actually should do providers of counsel
so can I just refer you to page 149 this
is my first go at this but there will be
more joint strategic needs coming online
in the neck
to be next cabinet or the cabinet after
that but just to give you the outline of
how we have to see this and you start at
the middle with you know who we are and
our lifestyle factors and then the
social community networks we have and if
you look in this the green section
healthcare services ie the NHS and
health care generally is only really a
very small proportion of it a lot of the
rest of what is going on there the
general social there socio-economic
cultural and environmental conditions
are things that we have a lot of
influence on so remember that little
rainbow because it's going to come back
again and again and again as we keep
going on about this so this these are
the first joint strategic needs reports
sorry and action plans so that covers
Stratford Henley study and Ulster and
coming online will be the rest of the
district which well it's it's
practically done it hasn't been
published yet it's coming to the health
and well-being board the next meeting I
think so that will give us the evidence
we need to support any decisions we make
which may or may not have a financial
effect but we don't know yet whether it
will so the recommendation at the moment
is that we receive the assessments and
recognise the statistical evidence base
through this process and that it should
be a material consideration in strategic
and operational planning
here counselor dark counts counselor car
gilliland counselor Perry thank you very
much indeed and thank you counsel Warka
this is our welcome this report and also
the fact that the Jason a we've been
using it now for a year in ulster health
and well-being board would you chair
that it's been a very very powerful way
of focusing minds I mentioned earlier on
when I was talking to you that we've
targeted forms of a better description
older people younger person's mental
health and carers and we're now moving
into social prescribing this looks a
little bit more one level up from that
and think like for example housing
quality although some things which is
one of the biggest factors in in health
okay what I'd like to say though is that
this this could be a very very important
part of our health provision and
well-being provision within the district
and I'm so keen to work with your sales
on this one on the officers in this bed
over there because I feel that we can
actually local health and well-being
boards can bring really fun to this
particular party and we've already
started it is a powerful document and
I'm gonna say very keen to start working
with you in the future
Thank You Kara Cargill I'm grateful for
that because I've just started as part
of the ship stand health and well-being
partnership to get together the same
sort of people in the NHS and across the
piece in in working on what we do there
and we're learning from what you've done
in old stuff so I'm grateful for that
and I think that this is going to be the
underpinning of so much of what we do so
thank you Calipari Thank You chairman
well like counselor Cargill I just
wanted to thank counselor Barker and
also NIC card for this excellent report
it does highlight some areas that
certainly raised a few concerns
me and a few surprises in terms of how
you know self-harm is higher in in
stratford-upon-avon than the county
level and that was a surprise also
concerning the numbers of increased
percentage increase in visitors to food
banks and being the highest area for
alcohol issues so I'm very much looking
forward to the wells borne analysis
coming through but this really gives us
a very clear picture and congratulations
to all the team but as I say it does
highlight some real real concerns and
that we can actually positively do
something address these issues going
forward and I think that some of the
concerns that are highlighted here
because we've really drilled down into
what's going on or things that we of
which we would not necessarily
automatically be aware those of us who
are on the ground perhaps as district or
County counselors become aware of it but
you can become overwhelmed by the fact
that you you know and you try very hard
to think then though there cannot be
this many people attending the food bank
and then you see the statistics and you
think rocky there are I know one of the
statistics in my patch and ships turned
that's come up is that seventeen and a
half percent of children are living in
poverty and the Warwickshire average is
11 and a half which to you to twin hurt
is over there you know how frequently we
have this argument in the County Council
about you know know my residents are
poorer than your residents and actually
oh gosh they are and so some of these
some this is great stuff for using to go
up against the assumptions that are made
about Stratford district because we are
not just you know a wealthy area we have
huge huge issues as everywhere else does
councillor Richards then councillor
Cargill again then
okay then counseling appendix to page
151 the the action plan table there's
some shadings in there some purple some
yellow some that just plain white I've
no idea what it means can someone
explain to me why it would be some stuff
shaded somes not and what exactly are
shaving means can I refer to mr. CAD cuz
I'm not sure what the shading means over
thank you
if I recall if I recall correctly the
shading denotes areas which the District
Council will have a role in facilitating
there are some actions within these two
action plans that are unique to it to an
individual organization but the shaded
ones are ones that we have a role we
have a role in or have complete
responsibility for delivering understood
if I may suggest that the shading
coloring is changed because I my
immediate reaction was the way I can't
read it but VI associated it with this
it might be worth doing something
different coloring for that's a minor
point okay thank you counselor card you
have to agree with us that couldn't read
the purple last ey can I just pick up
one of the little point that counsel
Barker alluded to us there this document
this this Jasna report actually also
focuses the minds of professional health
providers our surgeries that primary
care the NHS the the sisters who go
around the hundred community sisters and
each other now all of a sudden they
can't take we think you're wrong it's in
this document it's there we now need to
be able to focus on that and they have
to come along to the party
Thank You councillor Cargill councillor
kettle thank you for sharing the thing
that I think is a major long-term
concern on this document is
it's in green on that page where it was
in in the actual chord that the what's
called the affordability index is now at
nine point four times average salaries
to buy a new house new miracle loves our
speakers and Federation marketers last
summer when the I was able to identify
that the national figure was seven point
eight so Stratford as a district is more
expensive than the national position I
think that is of concern and twenty
years ago we're at three point six now
what that demonstrates is the MARTA
majority of houses and we're seeing huge
numbers of houses being built in
Stratford as we know and that's what we
do of the court structure and that's
targeting to do but what the evidence
that I'm saying in my own ward were as
you know there are significant number of
houses have been built is that the
pricing of new houses is way way way
beyond the capacity of those living in
the district all those who wish to live
in the district can actually afford to
buy that is a significant problem what's
also interesting is the pricing of new
houses is considerably more than the
price of an equivalent second house a
second-hand property the property
housing market seems to me in a very bad
place now that's not something we can
directly control here but what it does
demonstration some of the feedback I had
from that meeting was from members of
the Federation of master-builders who
tend to be smaller developers was that
everything they're doing to deliver
quality houses they are in competition
against big house prize who were sitting
market prices which they would like to
follow but they're not because they want
to sell the house they're building those
are the small builders and that this
authority should be doing everything we
can to support the members of the
Federation of master builders who are
able to meet much better
the needs of local aspiring residents
than some of the big house builders who
are putting these very large estates and
effectively having a monopoly on what
price will be set for standard two three
four five bedroom houses and if our
future does require this district to
have younger people in employment buying
houses
there's also change if those younger
people are having to commute into the
outside but I think your point is well
made and I think as he said
unfortunately we are not in control of
house prices and the ratio of incomes to
house prices is a major issue councillor
barker do you wish to respond on this
point just briefly on this point passed
I understand you know we're at nine
point four times that's that happens it
has happened in other places and other
times and it does vary I would suggest
that what we are trying to do very much
and I certainly am as people portfolio
holder is to encourage developments
where we get social rent because that's
that will make a huge difference I'd
also say that I've given advice in
another capacity to the Federation of
master builders or whichever one of
whichever one it was one of those one of
the two about what's going to happen
when the baby boomers sell their large
properties and I don't think that we
will be watching house prices climb
forever and ever and ever Thank You
councillor Barker chance legitimate just
to back up the what councillor Kepler
said there is there are close links
between the GSMA vulnerabilities and
areas where there will be a maximum
impact of of things to do with climate
change things like fuel poverty health
housing energy efficiency etc but what I
also want to draw attention to is that
the the area that has the most deprived
LSO a in ranks in the top is actually my
ward and it is repeated time and time
through their that it does need
attention paid to it and finally just on
a technical matter actually
my eyesight is such that I cannot read
the purple ones at all the contrast
between the purple and the black is such
I just physically cannot read them I
have not I've tried shining light on
them
I cannot read it so you know in in being
able to address all people and their
ability to read things please could you
take the purple part your point is
exceedingly well made councillor Jared
now then the recommendation on page 143
cabinets are you supporting the
recommendation and can I just say I
thought that was an extremely
interesting discussion which
demonstrated some considerable depth of
knowledge amongst members of cabinet so
moving on issues arising from OSC non
cabinet committees non on block items
strategic policy Advisory Group and this
is just to receive urgent business
one meeting close